so the wright
has been playing this game or even not
even just the right but people who just
believe in you know traditional values
basic american values totally seated
this space just totally seeded the space
and said oh it'll correct itself it's
self-correcting don't worry this isn't
some big thing guess what folks it is so
that's why we decided to put this
together they reached out to me and they
said do you want to do something i'm
like i don't know like what should i
write about and they're like what are
you they're like what's something that
you don't like and i said communism
right you know
and they said well we just so happens
that we have a book that we think that
would lend itself to that
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former navy intelligence officer the
senior editor at human events and the
author of the new children's book i've
got it right in my hand right now the
island of free ice cream jack pasovic
welcome to the reuben report
dave i am so excited and i just can't
hide it we're going to talk all about
the fact that there's no such thing as
free ice cream today
you know i've known you we met once in
person you've done the show once before
but i know you mostly through twitter
and if you would have said to me a
couple of years ago you think jack
besovic is going to write a children's
book i'm pretty sure i would not have
had that on my list but at this point at
this point
where we're at in the world it's like
pretty much anything's possible this is
proof of that i think
yeah you know and they reached out to me
so it's it's with brave books
and they have the whole thing up at
brave books so it's it's like ashley
sinclair and elizabeth johnston and
there's some other big names actually i
think they just announced it so i can
say this now that dan crenshaw is the uh
is going to be the next one coming out
with a book um
you know that was something we're like
don't say it yeah we're still you know
you know getting the the ink is just
getting dry everything etc etc but um
yeah we can announce that now and what
it really is is look when you walk into
and and it's a big thing for me too
right you mentioned a couple years ago
well a couple years ago i wasn't a
father right i didn't have my own kids
right i wasn't looking at life
differently i was just it's go go go man
hey you go back even you know 10 years
i'm in the navy i'm i'm deploying i'm
doing this i'm doing that you know i'm
not thinking about that stuff i'm
thinking about me right yeah right it's
it's it's when you're younger your life
is more centered on yourself that's just
how we are that's that's human nature
but you know as you get older and then
we do have kids and you start thinking
more socially being more socially minded
more broadly minded more
you know you have a more of a widespread
outlook on life and you start to think
well wait a minute what about what's
going on here what's going on there how
are we doing this how are we doing and
when you walk into one of these
you know commercial bookstores lately at
booksamilia and barnes noble i swear
it's like the first book i see it's
always this table that's set out and
it's children's books and every single
one of the authors their last names is
either a biden obama
clinton or a harris right mina harris
the niece and so i'm saying wow this is
just it's so politicized and i don't
remember that i mean you know my kids
books were like the last name was soos
you know like it's just basic
you know you mean that old racist right
right
you can't even do that you know i'm
learning like one fish two fish um and
now we're talking about all this really
politicized stuff and so i said look
there's been this idea on the right
that
you know it was always like it's always
like well the campus crazies will just
stay on campus because then they'll go
to real life and they'll get mugged by
reality to use the the old buckley in
line and then they'll stop and they'll
go back to normal and everything will be
fine right well that's not what happened
the campus crazies followed into the
corporate crazies the military crazies
the academia crazies all the crazies
right everywhere and so that's now
filtering into wear into schools right
pre-k through 12. and of course this is
happening we see trt etc etc and the
books are a huge part of this so the
wright
has been playing this game or even not
even just the right but people who just
believe in you know traditional values
basic american values totally seated
this space just totally seeded the space
and said oh it'll correct itself it's
self-correcting don't worry this isn't
some big thing guess what folks it is so
that's why we decided to put this
together they reached out to me and they
said do you want to do something i'm
like i don't know like what should i
write about and they're like what are
you they're like what's something that
you don't like and i said communism
right you know
and they said well we just so happens
that we have a book that we think that
would lend itself to that so we kind of
work together on the writing of it and
it's it's it's actually got and this is
the one thing i said to them i was like
look i don't want to do one of those big
preachy things where it's some story and
then all of a sudden you know jack
posobik walks over and is like well kids
let's talk today about the virtues of
the free market and miltonian milton
friedman and ein rand like no no no like
that i don't want to do that stuff right
so uh they showed me the storyboards on
and i said this is actually really cool
like this is a book
there's characters they're like on an
island there's a marketplace but then
you know some wolves show up and they
say hey come to our island we've got
free ice cream you know and this guy's
trying to not only i'm gonna illustrate
the island here there's a giant
i think i got it right here
oh my gosh yeah look at this right so
what the weight is we'll put up a still
so that i'm not so foldy here
i know right
so yeah though so the way it works is
with the whole series
and there's 12 in the first saga there's
going to be more sagas so it's like you
get one a month and then each one of the
books corresponds with one of those
circles and the different places that
are on that map are different stories
and they all kind of interlock i mean
you can read them out of order i think
makes sense as long as it's in the saga
but um each story kind of feeds into the
other one it's sort of a shared you know
like marvel universe kind of idea
but you know for kids that are reading
it and you know my son's three so i
showed him some of the storyboards and
he's like oh cool sheep and wolves like
like he kind of knows that wolves are
like bad and cheap are good but he
doesn't really have you know you know
ice and he knows ice cream is good he
gets that right
naturally
that's pretty basic um but he doesn't
understand so much the total plots yet
but he can at least get the action of it
right so they go to the island of the
wolves and guess what turnout spoiler
alert right it's not very good on the
island of free ice cream it's actually
quite bad and you can't get out and
there's like this berlin wall
surrounding it so it's like a cuba east
germany china kind of place
and um
anyway so that's kind of the story but
there's a lot of action to it and it's
interesting and then you get to talk
about some of these ideas and at the end
there is a little bit more of like that
whole educator piece where you know
we're working with like homeschool
groups we're working with religious
groups we're looking with a lot of
people who are just want to check out of
the system and say look we are not on
board with where you guys are going but
we need to find something to replace all
of this woke junk with and i said look
that's that's where brave books comes in
so it's actually really cool
you know you can start to have those
discussions like okay you know it yeah i
wish things were free too right wouldn't
that be great would wouldn't it be
awesome to live in the world of star
trek the next generation where there's a
replicator and you can walk over and you
know i've got my earl grey tea right but
we don't live in that world and so maybe
when somebody and it's just the basic
idea right that when someone offers you
something that seems too good to be true
it probably is
it probably is now the real question is
at the libraries will this book be
recommended by the drag queens during
drag queen story hour are they going to
be handing out this book i might be able
to sneak it in i don't know maybe while
maybe while they're getting all the
attention we'll just be running around
the back like throwing them all over the
place
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell